so we've got a real special presentation
of date also a co-director of the Yale
Energy Institute and is trying to help
us save the planet developments and
solar energy and you all are going to
get a hands-on today attempted doing
that yourself so without anything
further Gary Griffin okay can you hear
me let's see if this pleasure to be here
maybe yeah since curdle a lady and I've
got to have to tell you how I got
interested in chemistry growing up in
North Dakota how many have you been to
North Dakota anybody okay here's yeah a
few okay and so if you know North Dakota
there's not a whole whole lot to do
there but I was interested in rocks and
minerals and fossils but in the Red
River Valley there's mostly just black
soil and so the only place I could find
rocks and minerals and fossils were in
the rocks that they laid on the train
tracks walk these two walk along the
train tracks looking for interesting
rocks and minerals and one day train had
gone by carrying a load of sulphur and
some sulphur fell off the train was lame
by the train tracks and I picked up some
of the sulfur that was about ten years
old if you thought this is pretty neat
what can you do it the first thing I
found you can do it this burn it but my
mother wasn't too pleased when I was
burning sulphur anybody know what you'd
make when you burn sulfur sulfur dioxide
smells terrible so that wasn't but the
next thing I learned is you can make
gunpowder out of it and that's what
really got me interested in chemistry
and energy so that so that's my
background in in chemistry so what I'd
like to do today is talk about solar
energy and the the this is a problem the
topic of a lot of interests at and I
start with this slide from from Rick's
Molly Nobel Prize winner in chemistry
and this is towards the end of his life
he was really pushing energy research
and this is a slide from him listing
humanity's top ten problems in the next
50 years and number one on the list is
energy we really need to come up with a
sustainable process for powering our
planet
and so how can we do it I'd like to talk
a little bit today about how we might be
able to use solar energy to do that so
we use a lot of energy you know we use
it to drive our cars your heater houses
use electricity all kinds of energy it's
about you know some something out seven
to ten percent of our cost of looting
comes from energy and it's a huge
contribution contributes to about twenty
five percent of our trade deficit this
is a this this is a huge part of our
society how much energy do we use
there's that number right up there
sixteen terawatts it probably doesn't
mean very much you so you probably know
a wat you have a light bulb 100-watt
light bulb is burning that's that's
that's a measure of power that's being
used and 16 terra watts is sixteen
trillion watts and it said that's an
incredible amount of energy i did a
little calculation so imagine you have a
100-watt light bulb and it's about six
inches long or so and if you had enough
of those hundred watt light bulbs to
create to power this much power you'd
make a string of light bulbs that would
go to the moon and back 20 times that's
how much power we're burning even that
sounds like a mind-boggling amount of
distance in power this is a huge part
this is a continuous power rate that
we've used use in the year 2000 I were
more than that now you know so where
does that power come from where do we
get it so this is a picture i took out
of a scientific American article this is
a pie chart here and it shows in each
sector what fraction of the of our
energy where it comes from so this
Moorish sector here is Col this brown
sector here is oil that's natural gas
these three are the so-called fossil
fuels you know we dig them up out of the
ground and burn them for power this
sector here is nuclear that's not got
such a good reputation right now
especially with disaster in Japan this
brown sector here is water power and see
that little sliver there about two
percent that's renewables other than
hydroelectric we're hardly using any
renewable energy
and and just to give you some measure of
where solar fits on that so this is a
two percent is blown up into this pie
chart here and that little sector there
is how much solar we're using right now
that's the sliver what's that it's
expensive I'm going to talk about that
yeah that's right now so electricity and
solar energy from electricity was owners
expensive okay so why are we you seen
fossil fuel and you know where did it
come from so I'd like to start a little
bit of a history of oil so well was
discovered by the chat in China know
thousands of year 347 ad here's the
history so over the years we had some
oil wells hand dug in Persia sand oil
mind in France oil produced as a
byproduct of salt brine wells and the
first successful oil wells drilled in
1859 that actually has some Yale
significance does anybody know how Yale
connects to that first oil well other
than the front row people here okay
Benjamin silliman junior professor of
chemistry and this is a this is a
description that's written on sterling
chemistry laboratory and it was put
there in 1955 in a hundred years after
the this report that Benjamin so
unprepared he conducted a series of
pioneered experiments on the properties
and uses a petroleum gathered from
Springs near Titusville Pennsylvania is
detailed an optimistic report completed
in April sixteenth 1855 led to the
drilling of the first successful oil
well by Edwin Drake yep Titusville in
1859 and founding of the modern
petroleum industry didn't realize that
the petroleum industry was the
connection bounded here at Yale here's a
picture of that well in 1859 so that was
the first oil well in Pennsylvania so
that's you know that's we've been using
oil and and petroleum and other fossil
fuels for you know more more than 150
years now and why do we use so much
fossil fuel why is this what why is it
the power of the
we're using well it's really cheap
here's the cost on this axis here here's
a little chart showing the cost of coal
pretty cheap oil pretty cheap biomass
not too bad electricity right real
expensive so much more expensive
economically it's really cheap too to
want to use coal and oil and we've got a
heck of a lot of it this is some
estimates that had the oil and gas and
coal these are their proven reserves
these are estimations of how many years
of oil we have left gas and coal
thousands of years we have fossil fuels
to power the planet it's not it's not
going to run out and despite the fact
that people might might claim it will
run out there's a lot there Mike it will
get more expensive to mine it but it's
not going to run out and so this is a
conclusion from Nate Lewis who's the
director of the solar energy hub in at
Caltech is that these fossil fuels are
abundant they're inexpensive and they're
not going to because of that renewables
which are more expensive are not going
to play a large role in power unless we
have technological breakthroughs to make
solar energy cheaper or what is unpriced
externality basically we're not paying
the full cost of fossil fuel they're not
paying for the environmental effects
that they have and what are those how
many of you saw Al Gore's An
Inconvenient Truth or read to read the
book or so it okay this is the this is
the so-called hockey stick plot here
showing we're burning burning coal oil
and natural gas it produces carbon
dioxide it's going in the atmosphere and
before before the Industrial Revolution
is pretty constant and it's just taken
off you know why is that a problem well
have you heard of the greenhouse gas
effect you know so you have a green
house green house traps the heat inside
so it stays warm and our atmosphere acts
like like a blanket to to keep the heat
in it
on the planet so sunlight comes in makes
it all the way to the ground because it
passes through the atmosphere and now
the earth radiates back heat but that
radiated heat gets trapped in the
atmosphere if we have concentrations of
these greenhouse gases and carbon
dioxide one that we're generating by
burning all these fossil fuels is one of
the ones that's most most significant
yeah yet we do breathe out some carbon
dioxide and that does contribute and in
fact if we didn't burn all these fossil
fuels we'd be roughly at balance you
know the plants make oxygen I'll talk
about that in a minute we breathe oxygen
plants take up carbon dioxide we give
off carbon and it's pretty much in
balance you know so we're pretty much in
balance and we're upsetting that balance
by burning all the coal and oil and
natural gas so that's that's a good
point okay so that's the problem and
there's of course I'm not going to talk
about it but there's a huge concern
about the effects that this increasing
amount of carbon dioxide is going to
have on the climate and and the
environment so there's our there's other
aspects of fossil fuels that that of
course you're all familiar with there's
there's potential for problems with the
mining and production so you all know
about the british petroleum oil spill
almost exactly a year ago is when that
oil spill took place and this is a
pretty interesting picture that i got
from a colleague tom moore from from
arizona state university here's a here's
a BP gas station and here's the sign on
the station and you are responsible for
your spills well i'm not sure how
responsible british petroleum is but
they're still actually trying to
litigate in fact just this morning i was
reading in the newspaper that they've
been trying to distort the report that
came out of that so that's a you know
that's so we've got environmental
effects from production as well so um
what can we do well this is this is from
a speech from Barack Obama it gave about
a year ago like Carnegie Mellon news
says an American America run solely on
fossil fuels should not be the vision we
have for our children and grandchildren
and so he discusses how we need to be
pushing for renewables
and that's something I'm very much
interested in doing and and of course
very happy that the government is is now
taking the lead to provide funding for
this this is a program that was
initiated last year too by the
Department of Energy to fund their
so-called energy frontier research
centers and 46 of these were funded last
year at roughly 20 million dollars each
that's a big increase in research for
renewable energy and you can see you
know scattered all around the country a
couple of these dots here are from the
lr solar group which I'll talk about a
little bit more later is associated with
three of these energy research centers
and so we're working working to try to
you know improve the the processes for
solar energy conversion okay so with
that background he'll hopefully
everybody is on board that we need to we
need to think about how renewable
energies will contribute and you know
solar energy is I think by many people's
estimation the one source of renewable
energy that really has the capacity to
power the planet and I'll talk about
that in a minute more here's a little
cartoon to show mutts that what what you
doing mooch I'm trying my hand at photo
since with this how's it going you're
blocking my lunch so so actually this is
CEO so what this little yeah mooch is
supposedly photosynthesize it's not
actually completely far-fetched some of
you may be interested to know that there
are sea slugs who have photosynthetic
algae that grow underneath their skin
and they come out and curl on the beach
at in the daytime and lay in the Sun and
do photosynthesis and they cause a
symbiotic relation to the algae produce
takes solar energy produce sugar and
food for the the sea slug the sea slug
that swims out in the ocean and gets
nutrients that they need as well and
it's and so this is this not yeah it's
totally far-fetched but of course we're
not going to do that we need to have
some kind of a process where we could
use some make something useful and so so
what about solar energy so there's a
enormous amount of solar energy that
that strikes the earth in fact there's
enough energy
one hour sunlight to power the plan
remember that number terawatts 16
terawatts burn rate that we currently
have there's a bun enough that much
energy striking the surface of the earth
in one hour to power the planet and
photosynthesis in fact is collecting
about 90 terra watts of energy so you
know what are the you know why don't why
are we using more so legit whether
there's some big advantages it's very
abundant it's essentially free it's
everywhere low environmental impact but
the disadvantage is that it's very
diffuse meaning it's just you know very
low low amount of energy for every
amount of space and it's not constant
you know it's dark at night sometimes
it's cloudy like today and and so that's
a problem so we need to come up with
ways that make it cheaper you know so as
you've got the low-cost it to collect so
only so here's a this is a graph of what
we wanted shows the sunlight that comes
down to the earth is so the blue line
here we need to collect all these
wavelengths of solar energy and turn
them into something we can use and so
this is this is a graph of the map of
the world and on this map is color-coded
where it's sunny out the most so the
dark orange and and and yellow colors
are where there's lots of Sun look at
you northern Africa the Sahara Desert
lots of Sun there Australia lots of Sun
there of course in the Arctic region not
so much and and so obviously we'd like
to be able to use solar energy where its
most abundant and if you look on the map
here there's six little circles that
represent areas of land and if we use
that much land and can convert the
sunlight that strike in that area at ten
percent efficiency so if we get ten
percent of the sunlight that hits there
we could produce 18 terawatts we could
produce as much energy as the power to
power the entire planet what's that we
just run it all the time when the sun is
out there it's using it so we'd have to
have a solar farm in these areas here
that would collect the sunlight and make
it into something we could you
use that doesn't look like it's
impossible to do right you could bet
that's not covering that much to the
planet this needs it's just expensive
right now interesting question so we're
not using very much solar energy do you
know which country has the largest
installed solar energy capacity who
knows which country what's that you know
installed solar energy capacity Germany
now why is Germany it have so much solar
energy because the government is
subsidizing but look where Germany is
it's up here they're blue that's not the
best place to put solar collectors if we
wanted to do something smarter we'd put
it out yeah something where it's where
there's more solar energy somebody
mentioned China though China is
significant they are the number one
producer of solar panels and and they
are growing very quickly in that in that
area okay so the one of the problems
however with sunlight and we'll go back
to the last this last map here's the
Sahara Desert lots of Sun nobody lives
there right nobody lives in the desert
so you howdy so you have to transport if
you're going to collect solar energy
transporter where people are like up in
Europe and in transport of electricity
in particular has transportation losses
and also another big problem is you know
you've got lots of sunlight here in the
daytime but it's dark at night and so
the sun's not all the time so how do you
store sunlight well if we make
electricity electricity can't be stored
easily a good way to store sunlight is
to make fuel and we could have a fuel
processor for example you could make
electricity and use electrolysis and
give a storage that allows us to make
fuel they could power cars or buses or
you could make electricity again using
fuel cell so that that's what we'd like
to be able to do something like that and
so here's here's a sort of idea of how
we could convert sunlight we got some
sunlight coming in we've got some device
that can make electricity we already
have solar cells that can make
electricity and we could or we ideally
we could make fuel and so I'm going to
spend a little bit of time talking about
how processes of fuel production
happened in photosynthesis that's what
photosynthesis does it
makes fuel using sunlight and then we're
all end by talking about solar cells how
electricity is made and you see all this
stuff up here we're going to have I
activity at the end where everybody is
going to make their own solar cell if
you're if you want to come down got
enough to to everybody to do that and
you can see over here we've got some you
know some different colored materials
raspberries and spinach and beets and so
on of course to collect sunlight you
have to absorb the light and seen you
something colored so we're going to make
solar cells here these will make
electricity but as I said you know and
we already have solar cells but they're
they're kind of expensive that's the
problem and electricity can't be stored
so we'd like to understand from nature
how do you make fuel and could we do
that in an efficient way it with a
artificial process or like this we can
make a fuel like hydrogen for example so
how do you do that so for solar energy
conversion first of all you have to
collect it you need something that
absorbs light it has to be colored right
so we've got we've got stuff over here
like beets it absorbs lots of lots of
the sunlight if you've got something
really colored like beets and and so
that's the collection part we need solar
cells that will collect like so what
color what color are solar cells if
you've seen Kroon Hall Kroon Hall has
solar cells on the roof what color are
those solar cells blue I think they're
not maybe really really dark blue
they're they're really pretty black and
why are they black yeah right they're
black because they absorb all the light
and is all the visible light that's what
you want to do collection you want to
collect all the light so that's the
important first part is you need to do
that well Matt solar cells do they're
black and so they absorb all the light
yeah
time it's really sunny out then then you
and you don't feel notice that a while
later the can is hot yeah if you put
that's right you put black paper or
it'll absorb Sun and will get hot of
course that's making heat heats not what
we really want we want to make something
that we can use and heat isn't so you
actually told ourselves get hot too but
that's not that's not something that
we'd like them to do we'd like them to
make electricity's that's okay so then
you have to collect the light then you
have to do some kind of conversion what
what solar cells do and what all kinds
of light solar energy conversion
processes involve what I'll just go and
they take and make a charge separation
that is electrons move it makes
electricity and so that even even in
plants that's what happens and then that
electricity has to be converted some way
so photosynthesis is being it is using
the electricity to make fuel and solar
cells are using that electric just
making electricity so that's that's
what's a little bit about how these
processes work on a fail how did how can
we design a system to do solar energy
conversion well we can learn from nature
chlorophyll this is a picture of the
planet now but it was taken with in
color here now so that we can see where
plants are growing see this green area
here it northern North America and the
east coast lots of things growing there
you know what's going on over here why
isn't it so green there yeah that's a
desert there they're not so much not so
many plants are growing look at the
Sahara Desert nothing not much just
growing there either lots of so this is
on land looking in the ocean there's a
lots lots of photosynthesis in the ocean
yeah algae yeah this this green here
from algae growing in the ocean well why
isn't there so much growing out in this
parts of these parts of the ocean yeah
well algae don't have roots though yeah
they just float around in the water
they'd but but it's actually a little
you're on the right track yeah now
there's plenty of Sun out here
I don't yeah coldwell your temperature
is a but actually look up here that's
pretty cold and it's not stopping it
yeah mmm waves there's pretty much waves
everywhere it's not yeah no no yeah
there's currents but that's good
actually because then things can go mix
yeah yeah Chinese LG get eaten
everywhere that's what that did so much
yeah yeah what's that let's yeah well
there's salt water but that's actually
fine this salt water is here to let me
let me show you something here look at
this green that's sticking out from
Africa here and here you know what
happens in Africa the wind comes across
the Sahara Desert it picks up dust and
it blows it out in the ocean they give
anybody a clue as to what's going on ya
know so what is what what is it picking
up and blowing in that dust it's picking
up nutrients it has picking up nutrients
in the so here you've got more nutrients
and out here there's no not enough
nutrients that so there's actually kind
of interesting one of the ideas for
carbon dioxide absorption from in the
end of the ocean is to fertilize the
oceans and I think this is kind of a
crazy a crackpot idea but there is
actually a proposal let's go fertilize
the ocean and make more algae grow the
problem with that the algae grow but
then something else eats them and they
have just you know it doesn't really
amount to too much so so what we down
what we you know so photosynthesis is
actually you know really using light a
lot and we'd like to understand how that
works and so what are they what is what
our plants doing they're taking energy
from the Sun and they're making it into
food or chemical energy food is chemical
energy right you ate a donut out there
there was this great program the ascent
of man
and Jacob bronowsky and he talked about
energy in terms of jelly doughnut units
and he talked about the Tour de France
racers every day you know they'd use
lots of energy to race their bikes
they'd have to eat certain number of
jelly doughnuts to make that you know
resupply that energy so those jelly
doughnuts have chemical energy and what
photosynthesis is doing is taking
low-energy chemicals like water and
carbon dioxide and turning them into
high-energy chemicals that we can use
for food that's what photosynthesis does
now I'm not good for this is a little
more technical but what this is is it
basically taking these chemicals that
are low energy and turning them to ones
we can burn like hydrogen that's a fuel
so we need to think about you know how
can we for example split water to make a
fuel we need to have a source of a
chemical that that we could use that in
something that could be turned into fuel
in one a way that we could do that is to
split water that's that's that's a in
that and photosynthesis that's what
photosynthesis done does nature learned
a long time ago that water is a good
thing to use for production of fuel and
so this is the reaction that happens
carbon dioxide co2 water h2o are being
kind those are two chemicals low at low
energy chemicals some point in in the
environment and you make they make fuel
carbon this is biomass and oxygen which
is released in the atmosphere yeah
that's photosynthesis and you can see
the oxygen here's a picture I don't know
if you know these aquarium plants alodia
here's the picture melodia look at the
bubbles of auction you can shine light
on them off just bubbling off you can
actually see the bubble streaming out
and so if we look at the Earth's history
this is a these can be measured from the
geologic rocks how much oxygen was in
the atmosphere as a function of the time
before the president so the earth was
created about 4.6 billion years ago
oldest rocks about 4 billion years old
and starting about 2.3 billion you start
to see that there's oxygen and it grew
to a current amount that mysterious
about twenty one percent ox
right now we breathe that oxygen yes
this production of oxygen that happened
by photosynthesis of course it animals
start to be possible you couldn't have
animals until you had oxygen because
animals need to breathe oxygen in order
to carry out their their metabolism so
here's the process carbon dioxide water
low-energy chemicals very abundant in
the environment are being converted to
fix carbon biomass at high energy
compounds and this is a waste product of
photosynthesis is actually the oxygen
and that's being released into the
atmosphere now this fix we breathe out
we go the other direction we make carbon
dioxide and water from the food weed
that's right that's right these two
production photosynthesis goes this
direction metabolism what we do goes the
other direction so over the Earth's
history there's been excess more oxygen
has been produced then has been used and
so there's accumulated in the atmosphere
and that's balanced by all this biomass
that's buried in the ground and that's
the fossil fuels that we're burning yeah
they do right now right now we're pretty
much balanced and you can see the oxygen
atmosphere hasn't changed for a long
time that's because we're pretty much in
balance right now although we're trying
to make it go back again the other way
because we're taking these fossil fuels
and burning them and we burn them or
using up some oxygen when we burn them
we haven't done enough yet to change the
atmosphere you're not just your oxygen
stills 21-percent but you know that that
could be so i did a this amount of
oxygen twenty one percent that
corresponds to water that's being used
up and that amount of water would lower
the ocean level by four point eight
meters that's how much oxygen is
actually the option of the atmosphere
was pretty require that much water to be
to produce it's a lot of this has
happened on a huge scale over the
earth's history so one part of my
research group and I won't go into any
real detail about this is been to the
steady
the plot processes happening implant so
here's a leaf if we take a little
picture of a leaf and look at a single
cell here's a single cell and a plant
and inside those cells are these green
green organelles called chloroplasts
here's a picture of a chloroplast that
has these little structures membrane
structures that have all these protein
complexes that do the they have
chlorophyll they're the green components
that that absorb light and do the
photosynthesis so we're we grind up
spinach and there are lab we isolate it
there's some ground-up spinach up here
not ground up quite as gently as we
would do in a lab but nonetheless ground
up and we try to figure out what's going
on in photosynthesis in in these
processes here and we'd like to learn
from nature how can you collect solar
energy how can you make fuel from solar
energy and if we can understand that the
idea hope is that we can apply those
principles to artificial processes
whereby we could make efficient devices
that could make fuel from solar energy
and it's not a new idea this is a this
is an article that was written in
science in 1912 99 years ago by the
scientist Giacomo sheemish an and I'll
just read this to you is amazingly
foresighted you know nearly 100 years
ago it says on the arid lands there will
spring up industrial colonies without
smoke and without smokestacks forests of
glass tubes will extend over the plains
and glass buildings will rise everywhere
and inside of these will take place the
photo chemical processes that here there
to have been the guarded secrets of
plants but they will have been mastered
by humor human industry which will know
how to make them bear even more abundant
fruit than nature and if we're nature is
not in a hurry and mankind is well that
was a hundred years ago we still don't
know how to do it he spent his entire
life researching this and it's been an
area of a lot of interest but we still
have a lot to learn and this is an area
that we're working on in the chemistry
department and this is my solar our
solar group Victor Batista works with us
Bob Crabtree & Charlie's Martin Meyer
and the four of us had been working as a
team for about five years now
to try to do this to try to make fuel
using sunlight and trying to reproduce
the processes in nature so i'll call
this bio-inspired so we're going to be
inspired by nature to try to develop
processes that will work at to make you
so i won't go into any great detail but
basically what nature does is uses light
so these little lightning bolts are
supposed to be light and it uses light
it collects it by using chlorophylls
molecules that can absorb light it moves
electrons makes electricity and those
electricity is used for fuel forming
reactions and water splitting reactions
so we're going to try to do that same
thing but we're not going to use we're
not going to use chlorophyll and we're
not going to use the kind of proteins
and biological molecules but we're going
to use titanium dioxide ty teenie we're
going to we're going to see that we're
going to use this in our solar cells
titanium dioxide is like white paint
really cheap abundant and it also has
the property that we can use it in solar
cells so we're going to try to do that
in a very similar way to use light to do
fuel formation reactions and water
splitting reactions that will call this
bio-inspired artificial photosynthesis
that's where a research program is is is
geared at yeah natural photosynthesis
efficiency actually is not that high
that's an interesting question we just
had a workshop last year to talk about
really what is the efficiency here it's
not not that good actually if you just
grow plants in the field at grow crops
and harvest them the overall solar
energy conversion efficiency is less
than one percent so they're not very
good you can make artificial systems
that and we're hoping that these that
could be have efficiencies better than
ten percent they don't exist yet that's
the research that we were doing but in
principle that could be done and this is
inspired the use of titanium dioxide is
inspired by work that was done on the
so-called dye-sensitized solar cells and
we're going to make those so this is my
last slide I'm going to show you how you
can make electricity with solar energy
using these so they they use these this
titanium dioxide material titanium
dioxide as I said us in white paint how
many of you brushed your
this morning with toothpaste okay if you
swallowed any of that you ate some
titanium dioxide this morning because
the filler and titanium die and
toothpaste is titanium dioxide so it's
it's pretty abundant it's not it's not
toxic and it has the good property that
if you that it can be used in a solar
cell but titanium dioxide zweite what
does that mean about absorbing light it
doesn't absorb light because it's white
and so that's bad for solar cells so how
can you make it absorb light yeah you
could put paint on it put some paint on
it right that's where the dye is dies
the paint doing our paint paint this
titanium dioxide with chemicals this is
the one that's used in the commercial
dye-sensitized solar cells this
complicated molecule and this is what
one of those solar cells look like it's
got this red color should be black good
point it should be black we need to find
molecules that are black and work on
these then actually they're not they're
not they're the best one is actually
called black dye that's the one that
works the best this one's actually red
dye so it's not quite black yet but and
so I'm like we're going to make these I
want to just give a brief introduction
to what we're going to what they are and
how they work and then I'm going to turn
it over to some of my group to introduce
it further but what this titanium
dioxide this is this layer on the
surface is supposed to be white and you
put a dye on the serpent sticks all over
the surface so you sensitize it by
sticking the dye all of the surface now
the dye can absorb light and what is if
it works properly when it absorbs light
it will make electricity you can light a
light bulb and that electricity will be
moved over to form but to form a
complete circuit we have to move the
current back again to have a complete
cycle and there's a solution that sits
inside of these solar cells that has
iodine in it now you're you're all to
welcome to young but when I was a kid we
used to have the he went got a cut you
had to get ID and put on the cut to
prevent getting infection yeah so this
idea will see you'll use it when you
make your solar cell instead of this
this sort of orange color
don't want to put it on your cuts but
that that that allows the complete
circuit and so what we're going to do
when we make these solar cells is we're
going to take a one source slide here
there's going to be put on glass slides
that's got titanium on it titanium
dioxide on it we're going to stain it
we've got stuff over here that can stain
it you can choose what you like then
we're going to put this iodide solution
on it and we're going to put another
sandwich of the another glass slide and
we're going to make a sandwich that if
it works right it's going to make
electricity when we shine light on it so
that's what we're going to do and the
the plan is to have have groups I think
we've got 37 stations and I'm going to
turn it over now to to my group members
who are going to introduce how you make
these and we're going to pass out some
instructions and then once we go through
an introduction of how you gonna make
where he invite everybody to come down
and make a solar cell so I want to
introduce Carrie young she's a graduate
student in my group and she's done
really all the work yeah I just stand up
here on top and she is he's the one that
did all the work to put the solar cells
together and and she also is going to
tell you a little bit about how how the
how to make the solar cells okay now
what happened to the microphone oh there
it is okay okay and maybe before Carrie
get started let me introduce the others
who are going to help us okay over here
in yellow is Lauren martini she's a
graduate student working with our solar
group guys to houlis gary moore and
Lauren sky Lawrence is an undergraduate
it's student in our group and gary is a
postdoc and this one will advance it or
if you pushed it down and I'll turn it
over to Kari and she can tell you how to
make solar cells and we can get get
started hello everyone I as gary said I
am here to explain to you how to make
solar cells we're currently passing
around the instructions for that and so
the way this is going to work I'm going
to go through the whole process and you
can follow along on your sheets and then
we'll divide into groups and
up and get started that's your Easter so
I'll give just a second for the sheets
to catch up with everybody so here's
sort of the overview while we're waiting
will have some petri dishes with little
slides in them and you can see here are
our lovely assistants are worked out the
details okay I think you're getting
pretty close so the there are four steps
to making a solar cell in the first one
on your instruction sheet says sensitize
you're a node which is chemistry speak
for color your titanium dioxide so
you'll have a little piece of glass that
has some white stuff on it and the first
thing you need to do is choose a dye so
add I is basically anything that has a
color and something that you encounter
in your daily life that has a color are
fruits and vegetables so we have a
variety of fruits and vegetables that
you can use to dye your solar cells
please don't eat our dies and or
alternatively if you'd like we have a
couple of colored markers which are also
things in your daily life that are are
colored so you'll choose to die and if
you choose a fruit die then you'll add a
little bit to the shallow part of your
dish and then you'll just smush your
titanium backside covered your white
covered slide down into your die to let
the the colored molecules sort of get
get all over the tandem dockside and
stain it so what is this white stuff if
Gary mentioned the white solid is
titanium dioxide which is really good
for moving the electrons to make
electricity but not so good for
absorbing light we went ahead and made
your titanium dioxide slides for you
because so we start out and you make the
little rectangles and then we have to
heat them in an oven and we decided that
you didn't really want to wait for that
so and the reason that we do that is to
make it so to go from little particles
to a nice smooth surface and so then we
let them cool and then they're ready to
go so once you've
I switched your titanium dioxide slide
in your die for about five minutes you
can rinse it off and get all the extra
fruit off your your slide and then just
let that dry so then you have you know
the first piece of your your cellar cell
so the second step says prepare your
cathode which basically means make your
other electrode and you'll find in your
little kit a blank slide that has a
letter Y on it and there's a picture of
that drawn on your instruction sheet the
the slides have a what one side is
different from the other side but it's
hard to see that so we had the y on
there so that if you line that up then
you'll know if you have the right side
facing up once you do that then you can
use a pencil to color in a rectangle
just like the rectangle on your your
instruction sheet and so we're basically
using a pencil lead which is graphite as
an electrode material kind of like the
titanium back side but opposite if that
makes any sense don't worry about saying
inside the lines just make sure that
there's a nice dark layer that's about
the size of the rectangle on your sheet
the third step is to bring it together
and we're basically going to make a
solar cell sandwich so you'll have two
electrodes ready to go on the you're
colored tio2 slide you'll add a few
drops of that iodine electrolyte figure
II was talking about and so that's kind
of like the filling and then you'll
you'll add the other the other bread the
electrode the piece of glass from step 2
and you'll want to you want to arrange
them so that they're kind of offset so
the edges are sticking out so now we
have our solar cell sandwich and then in
your kit there are a couple of binder
clips and you can use that to hold the
whole thing together so that it doesn't
come apart we recommend finding you know
so some teamwork for this it can be a
little tricky and so then you have
completed making a solar cell once you
have your solar cell complete then you
can use a
a multimeter to connect a red lead to
one side and a black lead to the other
side and we're happy to help you with
this at that's tricky you'll turn your
multimeter to where it says VDC and then
we have a lamp here you can place your
solar cell under the lamp or take it
outside and the multimeter will read the
voltage of your solar cell which is
correlated to the amount of power that
it produces under the life so by the end
of today hopefully all of you will get a
chance to make a little bit of power
from sunlight and obviously the the
higher the number the better so the
number to beat is 350 7.1 if you can do
better than us then but don't know about
which side to put the clip on okay so
that we have we learned something from
this um so you want to you you have
these little hard to see here where
where you you arrange the solar cell so
that it was sort of slipped stacked you
want the metal piece to go on the same
side that you have the titanium dioxide
or this or the graphite so if this is
confusing than then just ask us and
we'll be happy to help um so with that
that's basically the the steps for
making a solar cell there are probably a
little more behind more than I'm a
little more than 100 of you and so
you'll want to form groups of maybe
about three or four people that you can
work with and we we have a bunch of kids
here we're also scientists and we know
how important safety is while we're
doing scientific experiments so the
first thing that you should do is find
your group and then you can come up over
here to this this corner of the room and
we have some safety goggles and gloves
and then you can grab a solar kit spread
out here on the bench and get to work
making your solar cell just one ball
that we cannot
we have a question so so the one though
that we made was 350 7.1 chaos ensues
gasps I think I'm because there before
the chaos ensues I'd like to wait wait
wait wait wait everybody over here yes
the chaos the chaos has ensued I was
going to say before the chaos ensues
it'd be nice to thank professor britvic
for the great talk